let's talk about how to increase your
height is it possible
yes it sure is
in practice over the years i've had a
handful of patients who had kids that
really were not developing and that
certain children in the family were
taller but another child
really was not growing like they should
and so they wanted my advice so i'm
gonna tell you what i recommended
because it was successful now normally
between age one and puberty
you should grow roughly about two inches
a year and then when you reach puberty
it should be about four inches a year
and then you pretty much stop growing
between the ages of 18 and 20. and
that's a generality because some people
stop growing a little bit before that
and yet others continue to grow a little
bit longer than that but that's roughly
the age
group that you stop growing so if you're
that age or less and you want to grow a
little bit more
what i'm about to tell you may help you
and of course there's a genetic
limitation however
if you are deficient in certain
nutrients
that can
significantly affect your
height
so the three hormones that are involved
in growth our number one human growth
hormone okay and that is produced by the
pituitary gland
and it works through the liver
the next hormone is igf-1 that's
insulin-like growth factor number one
and that hormone is made by your liver
and it's controlled by
the growth hormone and then we have a
thyroid if the thyroid is not producing
enough hormones
that can create a stunted growth so
let's start with the growth hormone what
could create a growth hormone deficiency
well the number one nutrient that can
affect growth hormone is
zinc so children with stunted growth are
mainly deficient in
zinc
and people with a growth hormone
deficiency are usually deficient in
zinc
so zinc is a very important trace
mineral needed for
more chemical reactions than all the
other trace minerals combined
and a couple things that will create a
zinc deficiency consuming too many foods
with phytates
and phytates are in all the grains
so all those so-called healthy whole
grains that
they tell you to eat
can create a major zinc deficiency and
then of course you have other things
that will deplete zinc
sugar refined carbohydrates alcohol
caffeine stress
not consuming enough foods or zinc like
let's say you don't consume any red meat
or
shellfish
or let's say you're a vegan okay
all those things can create a zinc
deficiency the other thing that can
create a growth hormone deficiency is
starvation
now i'm not talking about doing fasting
with all of your nutrients i'm talking
about starvation where you're starving
your body of all the vitamins minerals
nutrients amino acids essential fatty
acids that type of thing
now personally i think i stunted my
growth because i'm only six two
my dad's six five my brother is six
seven i think he could be six eight my
mom is six foot no she's five ten but i
am only six two and i think what i did
to stop my growth was i wrestled in 9th
grade 10th grade 11th grade 12th grade
and then starting in college before i
fractured my neck and you talk about
having to cut weight and starve yourself
through the season
that was me so remember one time i had a
wrestling match and i had to cut weight
and i was way over
so within three days
i dropped a tremendous amount of weight
and to do that
i wore these plastic bags and i
exercised pretty much all day and i
sweat and i barely drank
hardly any water i think i ate a few
celery sticks
and a couple french fries from
mcdonald's and a few other things that
were not the healthiest thing on the
planet but i was weak i was tired i was
pushing myself
and of course i made weight and then i
just totally pegged out again and that
went on for some years
so all that starving and exercise and
stress and lack of nutrients probably
had a significant negative effect on my
overall health
so as far as growth hormone deficiencies
you need zinc okay you also need enough
protein you need sufficient protein so
those people who do not consume enough
protein
can inhibit growth hormone and then
number three this is very important
sleep
apparently growth hormone works when
you're sleeping okay so if you're not
sleeping that well if you have sleep
problems and you're a teenager that
could be the thing that can set your
growth next thing on the list is obesity
the more fat that you have on your body
the less growth hormone that's going to
be activated and then you have other
factors like smoking or second-hand
smoking that can inhibit growth hormone
and also caffeine i mean think about how
many teenagers that are consuming
massive amounts of caffeine
and sugar which will deplete your zinc
now out of all the age groups it's the
teenager group
that consumes
the most ultra processed
junk foods so talk about nutritional
deficiencies now there's one more
nutrient that can create a deficiency in
growth hormone and that is
a lack of vitamin d now that's a common
thing nowadays with kids because they
don't go outside enough
pretty much sitting behind the computer
the great majority of the day
now as far as the other two hormones we
have insulin growth factor
if there's any damage with the liver
let's say for example your liver is
fatty because you eat a lot of
carbohydrates or high fructose corn
syrup
that can inhibit that hormone igf number
one and affect your growth
now when we get to the thyroid gland
thyroid gland is very sensitive to an
iodine deficiency
so with an infant or a small child or a
teenager that does not have sufficient
iodine that can greatly stun your growth
iodine is mainly in seafood
shellfish
uh see kelp and it's in other foods that
are grown close to the seashore but if
that food is grown inland chances are
it's not going to have much iodine so if
you're watching and you're a young adult
or you're a parent that has a child that
wants to maximize their height
these are the things that you want to
put on the list number one a good trace
mineral product that has zinc in it okay
because you never want to just take zinc
alone you want to take it in a blend of
all the trace minerals
number two
this is the product that i would search
out and find
and recommend it's called pituotrophin
pmg
it's a product that is sold by a company
called standard process you can look it
up
and i'm not affiliated with that company
but it's a really good product to
support the pituitary gland that makes
growth hormone and i personally
recommended it and saw the difference in
height of certain kids that took it you
just want to take one before bed for
about three months the next thing on the
list is to get a lot of sleep if you're
not sleeping that is a factor you need
to address i'll put some links down
below of what to do if you have
insomnia and this is a really common
reason why people are zinc deficient too
many phytates in the diet
phytates are in grains so you need to
avoid grains and that way you don't have
things in your diet that are actually
blocking zinc and then the next vitamin
of course is vitamin d ideally the best
way to get vitamin d is through the sun
okay get your kids out in the sun
several hours a day that would be very
very smart if they can't do it then give
them a vitamin d supplement all these
things are going to maximize your height
potential but you also must focus on
your diet and i think the best way to
figure out the healthiest diet you
should be on
is take a look at what everyone's
recommending especially the food pyramid
okay look what the government is
recommending and then use that as a
check sheet to do the opposite okay the
majority of your diet either whole
grains or starchy carbohydrates in the
form of potato
whole grain
rice things like that those are the
foods that you absolutely want to emit
from your diet they're going to tell you
to avoid saturated fats and consume more
vegetable oils now you want to consume
saturated fats and you want to avoid
vegetable oils
because you can do that safely because
your carbohydrates will be very low
because you're not going to be consuming
sugars now when they recommend consuming
fruits and vegetables they're also
allowing you to consume canned fruit and
even fruit juice as your fruit and
vegetables so
i don't recommend that because that
fruit juice is pasteurized and it's
so concentrated with sugar it's not
benefiting you in any way at all
now of course i'm going to tell you to
avoid red meat well where do you think
you get zinc
red meat is one of the best sources of
zinc
so in summary the best diet would be the
healthy ketogenic diet
now if you're trying to maximize your
height
should you do fasting
well i think you should do intermittent
fasting because one of the
potent
stimulators of growth hormone
is fasting but just to make sure you get
all your nutrients
let's say you just do the type of
fasting that you you avoid snacks and
you have three meals or even two meals
but these meals are really nutrient
dense i think that can help you
so anyway try some of the things i
recommended and then come back
and type in your comments down below so
we can hear your success story i think
the best next video for you to watch
would be on zinc check it out i put it
right here